es evidente
qué
las cosas están mal en el planeta altos
niveles de co2 junto con un aumento de
la temperatura
nos permiten afirmar que el cambio
climático es un hecho
pero estos son meramente síntomas de una
enfermedad mayor que enfrentamos en el
planeta
tenemos alarmante escasez de agua y al
mismo tiempo las inundaciones son más
comunes
el clima se está volviendo de extremos y
es un clima de extremos la
característica principal de un desierto
en este caso
de uno gigantesco
cuando el suelo se convierte en polvo lo
llamamos de certificación y
lamentablemente más del 50% del planeta
se está certificando
pero yo no vengo a hablarles de cómo
estamos dañando el medio ambiente
yo vengo a traerles una solución global
al cambio climático
el suelo
es la capa superficial de la corteza del
planeta
pero lo que pocos saben es que consta en
promedio de 20 centímetros los cuales
sustentan la vida terrestre
un suelo sano tiene la capacidad de
combatir el cambio climático la escasez
de agua y el hambre mundial
ya medida que el suelo pierde su
contenido de materia orgánica pierde la
capacidad de cumplir esas funciones
y la manera más efectiva de evitar que
esto suceda
es muy sencilla
cubriéndolo con pasto
el pasto desata un intercambio de
compuestos entre el suelo y la atmósfera
capta la radiación solar y la utiliza
para descomponer el co2
fijando el carbono en el suelo que sirve
de refugio para los microorganismos y
los nutrientes
y liberando el oxígeno en la atmósfera
a su vez a diferencia de los árboles
tiene una densidad mayor de raíces esto
éstas perforan la superficie del terreno
aumentando la capacidad de filtración
del mismo
el pasto convierte al suelo en la mejor
manera de almacenar carbono y agua
y los principales agentes responsables
de dejar un suelo sin cobertura
son la ganadería y la agricultura
convencional
la ganadería al meter ganado en ciertos
terrenos y dejarlos ahí estáticos sobre
durante un tiempo
compacta en el terreno a la par que se
acaban los pastizales
la agricultura
usando el arado voltean la tierra
eliminando la capa la cobertura natural
del terreno
los terrenos quedan descubiertos la
mayoría del año y son extremadamente
vulnerables a erosión por medio de aire
y de agua
cuando llueve en un terreno que está
totalmente descubierto debido a que
tiene muy poca capacidad de filtrar el
agua se satura muy rápido
en términos promedios tiene la capacidad
de captar solamente el 20 por ciento de
las precipitaciones que caen del cielo
el 80% restante
corre llevándose el suelo con él y
generando inundaciones
esta foto es una empresa que obtiene su
agua de terrenos utilizados para la
producción agrícola
el agua se ve café
porque por cada minuto que pasa están
disueltas en el agua 200 toneladas de
suelo
un ejemplo de esto serían
5 camiones de volteo por minuto si
calculamos el costo de esta operación
durante un día cuesta más de 7 millones
de pesos al día y esto sin contabilizar
la cantidad de agua que se está
perdiendo debido a que no se aprovecha y
está contaminada
si nosotros me diéramos la temperatura
de un terreno cubierto y la comparamos
con uno descubierto podemos notar que el
descubierto está muchísimo más caliente
en el día y muchísimo más frío en la
noche
a diferencia del cubierto que mantiene
su temperatura estable
en otras palabras el pasto es
indispensable para estabilizar la
temperatura de un ecosistema
que podemos hacer
si la agricultura y la ganadería están
de certificando el planeta y los humanos
necesitamos comer
es realmente necesario que destruir que
destruyamos nuestro ecosistema para
poder sobrevivir
yo no lo creo
y la persona que yo más admiro en el
planeta con su ejemplo de vida
ha demostrado lo contrario
yo crecí en un paraíso un lugar hermoso
en el desierto de chihuahua
empresa ganadera que hace más de 30 años
estuvo al borde de la quiebra debido a
terrenos de certificados
pero mi padre
supo darle un giro a la situación y
logró identificar el problema
gracias a que aprendió a imitar la
naturaleza ya regenerar los suelos yo
pude crecer viendo como los recursos
naturales del rancho año con año iban
aumentando mientras en el resto del
mundo era evidente que se estaban
degradando
resulta que durante millones de años el
pasto evolucionó en simbiosis junto con
el ganado
esto quiere decir que manadas de miles
de búfalos horizontes dependiendo del
continente iban pastando los llanos
pasaban comían usaban orinaban y
defecaban y debido a que eran
perseguidos por depredadores tenían que
estar en constante movimiento hacia
nuevos pastizales
de aquí a que volvían al mismo pastizal
este ya había tenido la oportunidad de
absorber el estiércol la orina y
fortalecerse de la misma manera que lo
hace un músculo después de ir al
gimnasio cuando descansa
nosotros tomamos este ciclo de la
naturaleza y lo imitamos y lo aplicamos
en un en una planificación de pastoreo
holística en la cual utilizamos ganado
para que coman el pasto para después
dejarlo descansar este pequeño cambio en
el manejo de la tierra desató una
regeneración masiva del terreno en la
cual año con año iba aumentando la
población de árboles que teníamos los
forrajes de pasto y la cantidad de
animales que el terreno podía aguantar
puede aguantar
y esto se hacía produciendo se hace
produciendo carne natural que no
necesita suplementos ni hormonas
a un costo más bajo debido a que no se
gasta en el alimento del animal
carne saludable
y no solamente sustentable
regenerativa del ecosistema un ejemplo
del impacto de esta metodología es este
rancho en el desierto de chihuahua
solamente con seis años de aplicar este
método
se lograron estos resultados
yo cuando la primera vez que vi a estas
fotos
a mí me pareció increíble y por lo que
puedo ver
ustedes también
los límites del rancho de mi padre
después del año más seco en 60 años se
veían a sí
como pueden observar un terreno está
totalmente descubierto
mientras el otro está totalmente
cubierto de pasto
se hicieron estudios del contenido de
materia orgánica que había de los dos
lados de la cerca y se encontró que un
lado se tenía solamente el punto cinco
por ciento de materia orgánica mientras
del otro se tiene un 5%
por cada punto porcentual de materia
orgánica que se aumenta en el suelo
aumenta la capacidad de captar
250 mil litros de agua por hectárea
en otras palabras mientras un tren no
solamente puede captar 125 mil litros de
agua
en el otro se puede captar un millón
250 mil litros de agua
es una diferencia simplemente abismal
de qué nos sirve captar agua en el suelo
esta presa
obtiene agua de red de terrenos
regenerados
el agua se ve cristalina
debido a que el suelo fue capaz de
captar las aguas de las lluvias sin
erosionar sé
una vez que se satura libera el agua
lentamente a la par que la filtra
generando caudales que son más
constantes más limpios y más resistentes
a la sequía
nacen manantiales naturales los cuales
nutren los mantos acuíferos de donde
nosotros tomamos el agua de pozo y lo
mejor de todo es que esta agua de aquí
está libre de contaminación
la metodología holística consiste en
analizar a la naturaleza como un todo
que está completamente interconectado
a partir de esto se desarrollan
metodologías que en vez de ir en contra
de la naturaleza la imitan
y se desarrollan procesos que permiten
hacer productos que no son sustentables
son regenerativos
si nosotros aplicamos esta metodología
en la mayoría del planeta
lograríamos captar suficiente carbono
como para revertir totalmente el cambio
climático al mismo tiempo dándole de
comer al mundo entero y de tomar
está en nuestras manos exigir este tipo
de productos que nos van a llevar a un
planeta y una sociedad más sana
nosotros vivimos buscando las respuestas
en el cielo
cuando en realidad las estamos pisando
[Aplausos]